Association of America mr. Jack Valenti
good evening to all of you here in this
Pavilion then those watching around the
world I don't have to tell you that
Hollywood is changing and possibly for
the better but two of the new filmmakers
who have replaced the old filmmakers are
not only young and vibrant but they have
given the world some of its most
thrilling and moving and most enchanting
movie going experiences working
separately or together they have been
responsible for the unbelievable total
of eight of the 10 all-time grossing
films
it's an incredible creative achievement
and ladies and gentlemen would you
please welcome the two new kids on the
block mr. George Lucas and mr. Steven
Spielberg
this year the Academy's Board of
Governors has voted an honorary Academy
Award to a man who many of us believe is
our greatest living filmmaker and all of
us know is one of the few true
visionaries ever to work at our medium
akira kurosawa has made 27 films in his
47 years as a director among them such
indisputable classics as Rashomon okiru
throne of blood Seven Samurai and Ron
someone once asked mr. Kurosawa if his
movies have a common theme his answer
was that they asked a common question
why can't people be happier together he
has put that question in contemporary
terms and in films of epic historical
sweep but always answered it in a way
that intensifies and finally transforms
our shared human reality into a thing of
awesome and often tragic beauty
before you say anything before you say
anything
some friends of yours have a message for
you social step over here dosa Madonna's
email Cubana de sensee Anoka a ratio
Manos and pesto sorry gotta hurry hi you
free sushi on Starz mo - what was
cruising sigue la no gangee no mo hos a
chaotic tagging Academy no talk of SEO
omaha Jana's bar a staff no pony a smart
a Iman oh ho burrito yo rockabilly shot
Alma's cruisers are cool right you eat
most amaretto mousse Jagannatha so nice
moist soil
Sekai denominational goiânia everybody
at the Music Center please join us
Hey
Oh do not die Henry panecillo it alight
a ago Tony Coelho Mimas
I am very deeply honored to receive such
a wonderful prize scotchy Itachi Uchiha
sanitizer dukka dukka scholarship by
this but I have to ask whether I really
deserve it
I'm a little worried nothing a la Hache
your mother he gonna lock up tonight
because I don't feel that I understand
cinema yet yeah so no egg no TiVo no
mother
Harish hande nayana Kino Socrates I
really don't feel that I have yet
grasped the essence of cinema Ganga
Yamuna subarashii sketchy philosophers
couch Shimano scum no apply him musa
kashi cinema is a marvelous thing but to
grasp its true essence is very very
difficult sketchy pashya korekara mo
sono ato yo suah regime you know
schemata many gender Rocco
Suarez Sarina homo Sony Totoro it's even
a ho ho Tata muqaddas what I promise you
is that from now on I will work as hard
as I can at making movies and maybe by
following this path I will achieve an
understanding of the true essence of
cinema and earn this award Georgia